In 1919, the Ford Motor Company opened its first assembly plant in Brazil.
More than 100 years later,...
...it announced the closure of their last three plants in the country...
...following the Sao Bernardo do Campo plant closure in 2019...
...in the industrial outskirts of Sao Paolo.
About 5,000 jobs will be cut.
In this video, these workers from the Taubate plant in Sao Paolo's countryside,...
...are protesting the closure.
Ford said in a statement...
...that it's reorganizing its production structure in South America...
...to increase margins and generate more cash flow.
The automaker's dealerships will continue to operate in Brazil,...
...selling cars brought from other countries,...
...mostly Argentina and Uruguay and offering services to customers.
The Sao Bernardo plant closed down in October 2019 after 52 years....
...and at a time when Ford only spoke of their intention...
...to stop production of trucks in the country.
Ford's plant closures in Brazil have to do with the crisis...
...caused by the COVID-19 pandemic...
...but also reflect changes in the global production and flow of cars.